good all right so again i'll be talking
about monte carlo simulation today uh
first a very brief introduction
about myself uh so like probably many of
you on the call i have a
math and science background bachelor's
in physics and a master's in operations
research
after i graduated college i was in the
military
on active duty and i continued to serve
in a part-time capacity
towards the end of my time on active
duty i ended up getting my master's in
operations research
and in 2013 i moved uh here to
minneapolis
minnesota and began working in this
college and analytics field at
general mills so if you eat cheerios you
need a ginormous product they're
headquartered here in minneapolis they
do a lot more than cheerios
as well um worked there for a couple
years and then i was recruited to work
at target also headquartered here in
minneapolis
where i was the uh the principal
designer of e-commerce
uh last mile networks for target worked
there for about six years
and uh just last month left to found my
own business data driven supply chain
uh essentially it's my skill set
applying data science and artificial
intelligence supply chain if you want to
know more about that feel free to
contact me separately uh
i've been in our user since 2012 pretty
much since i was looking for a job
and i've just found it become an
increasingly powerful
language for all sorts of spletch and
analytics and
been a loved math and map since i was a
little kid which is probably uh
indicative of me going into this career
field all right
today's agenda how can we use data math
and advanced analytical methods to
understand risk and uncertainty
uh an introduction to the flaw of
averages and thinking in terms of ranges
not single values and then i'll give a
conceptual introduction to monofilament
simulation and a very
simple uh example of it hopefully uh
you know this is by no means intended to
be a comprehensive treatment of monte
carlo simulation
but hopefully it'll get you excited
about exploring it in your work
all right first off how can we use data
to understand risk and uncertainty uh
you know most people are
inherently paralyzed by uncertainty and
we tend to ignore it in our lives
there's just way too many things that
could turn out to be
different than what we're expecting you
know so our decisions are
typically made based upon either
heuristics or you know good rules of
thumb
or a single estimate which may or may
not be useful in the particular
situation like for example uh
before covid i i flew quite regularly
and so i knew how long to plan for right
i knew i needed to take 10 minutes to
the airport 15 minutes to security five
minutes for the flight right 30 minutes
um well things have changed right next
week i'm actually going on my first
flight some covid and i have no idea
what security is like i have no idea
what to expect
and so my past experience actually is
not useful
for uh for making decisions about the
future
you know and what's worse about this is
that our ability to
objectively evaluate decisions uh
actually declines the more complex and
uncertain the
decision is about the important details
you know for example
uh should i go to college and if so
where you know for some people the
answer is clearly yes some people it's
clearly no
most people probably somewhere in the
middle uh and so
what's interesting is that the tools of
monte carlo simulation and other
analytical methods from my field of
operations research
are actually quite useful for
understanding how do we make important
decisions under uncertainty
and so while i'm not here to give you
life advice on your education or your
career or your marriage
hopefully i can give you a little bit of
mathematics to help you with some other
things
and here are a couple books that i'd
highly recommend on a website if you are
interested in knowing more about
decision making under uncertainty
okay so for those of you working in the
business world you
know that in nearly all business
decisions future projections for
example sales forecasting or how much a
material is going to cost
six months from now these things may be
presented as a single value like we're
gonna sell
a thousand widgets next month or the
cost of paper will be
ten dollars but really nobody knows that
precisely
uh those would be more accurately
represented as a range
you know or a distribution you know to
actually use the math terms
and so making decisions based upon a
single point value
of those inputs typically the average
ignores the impact if those inputs come
in much higher much lower
than that one input you know dr sam
savage he's a operations research
scientist he popularized
the phrase the flaw of averages of
course that take a take away from
the phrase the law of averages for
mathematics uh to popularize this very
common mistake
and he he wrote about it in an article
in harvard business review
links up there and also a subsequent
book both of which i highly recommend
the phrase that dr savage uses that if
you're six feet tall
and you can't swim it's okay to walk
across a creek if it's four feet tall
right it's gonna be
up to your chest if it's four feet deep
sorry uh four feet deep the entire way
but if it's an average of four feet some
parts are two feet some parts are 20
feet
if you can't swim you need to understand
the distribution
of those depths there because you'll
drown uh and so
purely looking at the average rather
than the distribution of those
uh inputs could literally be a color
right so
that's the phrase uh the dr savage
folder pulled together
okay so monte carlo simulation
uh what is it um for those of you
maybe have a little bit more background
in it this is not a textbook definition
but i
think it's really useful for conveying
the idea um
it's an analytical method that evaluates
a lot of potential combinations of
uncertain inputs
drawing from the range of possibilities
of each of those inputs
and calculates the overall outcome so
if you could think of a function k or
a value k being the function of three
input variables x y and z
if x y and z are not single point values
but rather are themselves distributions
uh my color simulation helps you answer
the question well what is the
distribution of k
and so you know and what are the input
what are the real world impacts
of different segments of k's
distribution
so if each of these variables yield a k
an output variable k that's normally
distributed
the middle of that distribution is going
to have one potential outcome but the
the high and low tails are going to have
very different impacts upon
upon your real world operation and so
mighty color simulation helps you
understand
what both what is the outcome
distribution
and what are the impacts of those uh
this is really commonly used in finance
for you know stress testing
is uh that the federal reserve requires
is an application of it
the oil and gas industry uses this
because they need to understand what is
the potential
financial impact of say drilling a new
well or any sort of
any sort of investment and in my field
supply chain
monte carlo simulation can be used in a
number of different ways
one it can be used to understand the
impact of uncertain sales
in the future upon different warehouses
and trucking segments in the splunk
chain
it can also be used to understand
investment decisions
around hey do i need to buy more trucks
do i need to buy more inventory to
anticipate for sales right there's a lot
of
different uncertain questions that
will impact the supply chain and monte
carlo simulation can be used to evaluate
this
in today's example i am actually
intentionally not using a domain
specific example because i want it to be
accessible to anybody on the call
and i really hope that it will spark in
your mind how you can use my carlo
simulation in your work
all right so a very brief review of the
normal distribution
so those who probably seen this before
you know normal distributions also cause
a gaussian distribution or
a bell curve it's a continuous
probability distribution
that is described by two values the mean
or the average and standard deviation
um the image on the left is a represents
the distribution of pizza delivery times
after an order is placed
so the mean is 30 minutes right down the
middle and a standard deviation is 5
minutes
with a normal distribution it is
symmetric around the mean
and that means that a value of one
standard deviation over the mean in this
case 35 minutes
is just as likely as a value that is one
standard deviation below the mean or 25
minutes
so you can see that the height of the
probability distribution represents
probability
and so at 25 minutes and 35 minutes it's
the exact same height
standard deviation also can be used to
describe the likelihood of a range of
outcomes
approximately 68 of the values are
within
plus or minus one standard deviation and
then 95.5
within two standard deviations and
nearly everything within three
tail risk is those unlikely but
impactful outcomes
uh that happen when you get the real
extremes of the probability distribution
so in this case if i'm expecting a pizza
to come in 30 minutes
and it comes in 15 well hey maybe i was
planning for a party right
waiting for people to arrive food way
well now my pizza's there people haven't
arrived
and then anticipating it 30 minutes and
it comes at 45
people are going to be hungry right it's
going to have an impact on in different
ways
in my example for monte carlo simulation
all the inputs will be normally
distributed out of just convenience of
the talk but just keep in mind that in
real life
not everything is normally distributed
okay
all right so money color simulation
example so uh
this is the what i'll use to show the
power of monte carlo stimulation
keep in mind this is both fictional and
pre-covered
so it is doubly fictional don't so
please keep that in mind
uh i i neither worked in downtown
minneapolis nor use the bus anymore
all right so my my neighbor bob and i uh
we both worked in downtown minneapolis
and we take the same bus from our
neighborhood to downtown in the morning
and then back home in the evening so
same bus route uh
bob's a good guy i'd even say he's a
friend so we decided that hey
one night on weeknight we're going to
make reservations to go to a restaurant
in our neighborhood
we'll get a reservations at 6 15 p.m
we'll leave our office at 5 30 we don't
work in the same place but you know
we'll each leave our desk to 5
30. we'll go to the bus stops take the
buses back
to our neighborhood walk to our home and
then whoever
you know will wait for the the one that
shows up later then we'll walk to our
walk to the restaurant will we make it
on time
well i don't know mobster doesn't know
you probably don't know
maybe monte carlo simulation will help
us know though
all right and if you're interested in
following along at home please log in to
the
app there and i'll actually put that in
the chat as well
or if somebody somebody else could i
would appreciate that because i can't
really access
text right now i can do it all right
thank you
okay so a little bit more specifics of
this
i'm at the top here and i'm going to
leave my office
at 5 30 p.m i'm going to take
the minneapolis city bus back to my home
and my commute time from when i leave my
office
to when i get home is normally
distributed
with a mean of 30 minutes and a standard
deviation of 10 minutes so that's a
nomenclature for normal distribution
mean and standard deviation my next door
neighbor bob
he also has a 30 minute commute even
though we we don't work in the same
office
uh they're close enough where our
commutes are are roughly equivalent
and so both of us will have a 30-minute
commute from
the more the moment we leave our office
to the moment we get to our
to our front doors normally distributed
with a 30 minute average
and a 10-minute standard deviation
once we both get home we'll then walk to
our restaurant in our neighborhood
and that is normally distributed with a
average of 10 minutes and a standard
deviation of two minutes
so if we plan our schedule based purely
on the average
we'll both leave 5 30 the average is 30
minutes
that's 6 pm average walk to the
restaurant is 10 minutes that's 6 10 p.m
our reservation is 6 15 so if we plan
purely on the averages
we will show up five minutes early
one thing that's important to keep in
mind is that we may not exactly we may
not take the exact same bus
the bus runs every few minutes so if i
show up to the bus stop right when bob
or right when the bus is pulling up i'll
get on the bus whether or not bob's
there
vice versa so that's an important uh
thing to keep in mind
okay so if you're already in the app
you'll see a table like this at the top
i'll go over how to read it and then
then we'll switch over to the app so as
i
mentioned earlier monte carlo simulation
is a way to take input variables as
distributions
and understand the in the distribution
of the outcome variable whatever that
function is
in this case the input variables are my
commute time
bob's commute time and our walk time to
the restaurant
okay uh the outcome variable is our
arrival time at the restaurant and then
whether or not we made it in time for
our 615 restoration
uh with monte carlo simulation we can
actually simulate this
many many times and we'll do it uh five
thousand times actually
in this first example uh i lift
left at 5 30 pm and this is all in the
24 hour clock um
my commute is just a little bit above
that average of 30 minutes so i arrived
home at 6 00 1 pm
bob also left at 5 30 pm his commute was
24 minutes
so he arrived actually a little bit
earlier than me so the later arrival i
was later arrival
we left our homes at 6 00 1 pm once i
shut when i showed up
our walk time to the restaurant was
about 10 minutes 10 and a half minutes
which meant we get to the restaurant at
6 11 p.m
did we make any time yes we did four
minutes
in the second simulation my commute was
21 minutes
bob's was about 19 minutes so we both
got home actually quite early
quite earlier than expected so we
got both got home by 5 51 pm
then we took about 11 minutes to walk to
the restaurant so we get there
13 minutes early quite quietly right but
we made it in time
all right third simulation
my commute was dead on 30 minutes bob's
was a little bit longer
but you know by the time we both showed
up at home
and walked the restaurant we got to the
restaurant two minutes early so we're
good
okay
and in the fourth simulation things kind
of kind of went sideways here so
my my commute was only 17 minutes uh
but bob's was dead was nearly an hour it
was 50 minutes long
and so we didn't actually even leave our
homes until
6 20 p.m after our reservation
add insult to injury we took a lot
longer than expected to walk to the
restaurant
and so we actually missed our
reservation by almost 20 minutes
okay
now i just talked through four instead
of talking through 5000 more we'll
actually just let the computer take care
of it and then we'll go from there okay
all right so if we do this 5000 times we
actually
only made it on time for our reservation
about 47 percent of the time
it's that another way you only have
about a 47
chance of making it on time if you plan
purely on average
okay this is the power of monte carlo
simulation
by looking purely at my planning factors
i was going to show up five minutes
early
by using monte carlo simulation i can
actually see that
i'm less than half the time i'm going to
make it on time
and that's really really powerful
so i will actually then
transition over to working from the app
reload here so left hand side the
control panel
and i'll say i am not a real i'm not a
shiny developer i kind of just hacked my
way into this
for the presentation so uh appreciate uh
or apologize kind of the
entry level visuals here uh number two
is to simulate it defaults to 5000 you
can you can put whatever you want
uh we both depart at 5 30 pm uh this is
the shiny time
add-in our package for it and our
commute is 30 minutes
and you can adjust this with standard
deviation of 10 minutes and our walk
down to the restaurant is 10 minutes
with standard deviation too
okay
it's good point robert we'll actually
get to that in a minute
uh okay so again this is a table
the result of all 5000 of our simulation
here's a histogram of our arrival time
uh if we made it in time it's in blue
and if we didn't it's uh it's red
and it breaks at that 6 15 mark
here's the histogram of my commute time
from the simulations as you can see
it looks you know approximately normally
distributed right around an average of
30 minutes
and then the one and one standard
deviation and two standard deviation
marks
are are those vertical lines
bob's commute time is also a histogram
you know average of
30 minutes and our walk time is a
histogram
at an average 10 minutes okay and
i'll ignore those for now okay so
question for the group uh
if we are only making it on time
uh you know approximately 47 of the time
what can we do to make it more likely
that we will arrive on time
anybody answer please put in the chat
leave earlier thank you i was really
hoping somebody would say that right
away
okay uh so let's this is the
again the power of money color
simulation all we need to do is change
the inputs i'm going to leave
no not right not done i'm actually going
to leave earlier
i'm going to leave at 5 15 p.m bob will
still leave at 5 30 and now
instead of making it on time 47 of the
time we now have
a 67 probability
okay thank you brian that was actually
going to be the next one um
and if bob also leaves at 5 15.
you know so hang hang in a little bit
uh the probability goes up to the high
90 percent okay here we go 95.
and what you see is that once we
actually
start leaving even earlier than 95 then
515
the probability actually doesn't go up
that much um
okay all right joe and brian
yeah you guys hit the other one you got
to lower the standard deviations of the
commute
so one of the things about monte carlo
simulation is you
you actually get to understand the very
you know the variability of or the
impact
of the variations on of those input
distributions
and so yeah i mean if we have
a more dependable commute
that is not 30 minute standard deviation
but rather
a five-minute standard deviation
that improves our our reliability from
47 to 67
right there if we can get it down even
more
down to say a three minute standard
deviation
you know we get it to an 86 reliability
what that essentially means is that
by lowering the standard deviation of
the commute we're getting our
commute time down to that one single
point estimate of 30 minutes
that we'd been planning on initially
variability is the death of operations i
i totally agree okay um
so i mean you can play around with this
uh that's kind of
the the cool thing about doing my color
simulation uh but we caught
the two big ones um all right
so question for the group uh what is
the magnitude of being five minutes
early uh versus five minutes late
or what's the what are the different
impacts of being five minutes early
versus five minutes late
yeah listen to your reservation yeah if
i show up five minutes early
i'm gonna make my table i show up five
minutes late
maybe maybe not if i show up 20 minutes
early
i'm definitely gonna make my table but i
just wasted 20 minutes my life
if i show up 20 minutes late i'm
definitely going to miss my table
and so even though you're wrong in the
same way you're 20 minutes off
the impact is very very different
and that's one of the real powers of
monte carlo simulation is you can see
hey
if i am wrong on my inputs i'm going to
be wrong in my outputs but i'm going to
be wrong in different ways
and that really helps drive the
conversations around how does this
impact
our operations like am i okay being 20
minutes early but not 20 minutes late
maybe i value my time so much
that i don't want to be 20 minutes early
and so i'm going to change the way i'm
not going to you know show up to the
restaurant so early
thank you thank you all but uh we hit
the the main answers i was hoping we'd
hit
all right so quick question what is
unrealistic about this simulation
i intentionally put a few things in that
were more unrealistic
as a conversation starter what are some
of them
normality of the bus route absolutely
yeah uh most transit times are
are exponentially distributed okay
yeah yeah we don't exactly yeah we don't
have to
arrive precisely on time absolutely one
yep yeah so really it's more of who's
the first person to show up
that's part of it what's another thing
uh let's go back to the fir the very
last example that i gave
what's really unrealistic about this one
okay oh brandon yeah you got it
independently can you time
yeah the fact is that if my me and my
neighbor are both leaving downtown
minneapolis and traveling to our
neighborhood
at the same time the traffic conditions
are almost going to be
i mean they're going to essentially lead
that we're going to have very similar
commands
now it's not we don't necessarily need
to have the exact same commute time like
i've
been on a bus that broke down on the
side of the freeway the bus right behind
me just went right by us
and so my commute time was a lot longer
than the bus that went right by but for
the most part
the conditions that impact me and my
commute are going to impact my neighbor
as well
and so that actually leads to
the one of the most important things
when you're doing an actual monte carlo
simulation study
is you need to both define the problem
and you need to talk through the details
because in this case the two input
variables my commute time and bob's
commute time
they're not independent they're heavily
correlated to each other
and when we're going to draw from a
distribution that represents those we
need to understand that correlation
all right thank you
yeah thank you brian okay so takeaways
uh monochrome simulation is an
incredibly helpful tool for
understanding the potential outcomes are
in certain
inputs really any platform that can
generate random variables can be used
our python if if necessary excel and it
really helps
spur important discussions on a range of
outcomes and the impact of decisions
so thank you all for your time um
there's my contact information if you if
you care to reach me and uh
look forward to any questions i have
and i'll put all this on the website
when i get him
thank you so much ralph that was great i
uh i'm scrolling through
the chat to see if there were any
questions yet
so feel free to ask live or put them
into the chat
one comment i had and i think it would
be cool to take this application and
apply it to the boston
train schedules i wonder if that's
something that
we'd be able to do
yeah i know the transit agency here in
minneapolis keeps very good records of
this
sorry my internet froze for one second
but i see a question from joe if you
want to ask that
live yeah sure um i was just wondering
what type of
information about the relationship
between the two commutes you would need
to properly run the money carlos
simulation do you just like
set them as correlated or do you need
more information
yeah i mean i would say you'd you would
set them as as understand the
correlation but
ideally you would have some sort of
predictive model that
generates it like for instance in
minneapolis if you're going
going home during a three-foot snow
storm it's gonna be a lot slower than
you know a friday afternoon with with no
traffic
right so there's a lot of conditions
that lead to that distribution that you
then draw from
yeah it's a great question thank you
i know you mentioned that was just like
a basic shiny application that you use
but i'm curious if you have any
tips for people just getting started as
well or something that you learned from
from making that
yeah uh reactive data frames are uh are
a tricky concept to get to
uh and actually kai i really appreciate
talking through the
how you how you got it around it because
i mean i think you all
saw as i was changing things in the app
it was lagging
right and as soon as i saw that
universal sky i'm like oh man i wish i'd
do this
yeah it's a really um fundamentally
different
way of thinking about coding um and i
came from a um pure sort of r for data
analysis background and i would say if
you guess
if you're just getting started in shiny
the the one part of it where i do
recommend
watching tutorials and reading things
instead of just jumping into it
is like really getting your
understanding of what reactivity means
and how it works because that is the
fundamental difference and it's really
confusing
but it's very powerful once you learn it
kai i know you mentioned you have some
helpful links that you
can share when you share the slides but
be really great to know
like what um videos are most helpful for
them yeah for sure
um i started out just with the tutorials
on the rstudio website there are a
couple different formats i really like
how our studio
makes tutorials available to people who
prefer to read or people who prefer to
watch videos
so i started by watching a video
tutorial and
following along with the examples and
i'm also going to link to some articles
um yeah and then if anyone doesn't know
about the r for data science slack they
have a specific
channel for help in shiny and so i use
that a lot and that's how i found people
who are willing to sort of pair program
with me as well yeah cool
gary i see you have a question on the
simulation do you want to ask that one
live
uh sure yeah so i was just thinking
about say you ran the simulation five
thousand times
which i mean for probably only two
normally distributed variables makes
sense
but as a heuristic when you start you
know
you're trying to apply this to let's say
a fortune 500 company
that has probably tens of thousands of
different distributions that could be
tracking
how many simulations really do you need
to start running at that point
and you know what is the best way to
decide that
yeah so there are formulas that uh to
understand the relationship between the
number of trials and the confidence
interval
of your output variable you know and so
if you want to say i want to make sure
that i get
you know a 95 or 99 confidence interval
there's formulas to understand that
on a just kind of a practical level it
just comes down to
what's the relationship between the
compute time and how much you're willing
to wait
you know because if it's something that
you're doing once a month and you can
run it overnight
there's no reason not to rank you know
really jam up the number trials
particularly if you really care about
the tail risk
okay if i really want to understand what
is the likelihood that we're going to
get to the restaurant
at 7 00 pm you're going to need a lot of
trials to
to really quantify that
thank you
rachel do we have time for a couple more
questions i had someone ask a question
in the chat that i'd love to answer
with for everyone definitely so i had a
question in the chat about
um the functions that i used to handle
the colors the rgb
and the hex codes so i wanted to mention
two things
um first of all i used the color picker
package
from um uh dean atelier
i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing his name
correctly but that so that was a package
the color pickers
and then i used some functions rgb to
hex and hex to rgb to convert back and
forth
um so that would be my other uh
general advice for people working in
shiny is that a lot of people have made
a lot of really great infrastructure and
if you can rely
on that sort of thing um people have
it's possible people have already
invented what you think should be
invented which is really exciting and
can sort of stand on the shoulders of
giants
um i'll also share the code if you want
to look more in more detail at the
functions that i used for the colors
awesome are there any other questions
that i missed in the chat
or that you saw
scrolling up i don't i don't see any
others unless there were direct
direct ones to you um kaya or ralph
if um if anybody would want to or
if you have other questions and maybe
you want to connect with each other it
could be helpful if we
put maybe our linkedin
links right there also as kaya mentioned
there's the r for data science
online learning community i think that's
a great way to connect with everyone as
well so
if you're not on there i'll just put the
link to join
but thank you so much kaya and ralph for
awesome presentations
uh as i mentioned this was recorded too
so i'll put the link to the recording
on the meetup discussion page i'll do
that right now
but if anyone has any other questions
for the speakers or if you
maybe want to give a talk next time
please let me know and reach out through
meetup or linkedin
i'd love to hear from you
[Music]
you